Ein forschungsteam hat direkt in unserer nachbarschaft einen erdähnlichen planeten entdeckt der tatsächlich
Außerirdischen bei marken könnte er löst damit die planeten, im treff ist system
Als nächste exoplaneten mit der chance auf leben ab und ernährt sich und sogar und wird bald näher als proxima centauri
Sein wie es die lager auf ross 128 b jetzt ein klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Als sich diese meldung entdeckt, habe da machte es bei mir
Klingen da war doch was am 12 mai diesen jahres
wurden sehr seltsame signale auf der erde empfangen sie stammten vom zwerg sterne ross
128 das
radioteleskop in treptow rico empfing signale die zitat aus breitband pulsen die nicht polarisiert waren und sich quasi
Periodisch wiederholten bestanden so abel mendes vom arecibo radioteleskop aber was ist das für ein signal
sofort sprechen alle über aliens und außerirdische signale doch auch wenn das selbst den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern sofort durch den kopf schießt zuerst gibt es zahlreiche andere möglichkeiten das wären zb flairs
also
strahlungs ausbrüche des sterns allerdings
Während die frequenzen viel niedriger und die steuerung der signale pass nicht möglichkeit zwei eine falsche?
Zuordnung der signale aber es gibt keine objekte in richtung von ross
128 also auch nichts für impulse von
satelliten allerdings geben die nicht solche signale ab also auch busse und ja also doch signale von außerirdischen
Zitat wir haben hier ein mysterium jede der drei erklärung ist im moment so gut oder schlecht wie jede andere das sagt mendes aber
So mendes das heißt noch lange nicht dass es ein alien signal sein muss und auch selbst schostag
vom seti projekt das sind die die nach außerirdischen signalen suchen hält erst mal den ball flach
Keine bestätigung es gibt noch
Zahlreiche andere möglichkeiten und bis heute wurde keine wirkliche erklärung gefunden so wird er eine störung durch satelliten vermutet aber
Eigentlich passt das eben auch nicht und jetzt ist etwas passiert dass diese entdeckung
In eine vollkommen anderen licht erscheinen lässt jetzt werkstatt
128 wird von einem erdähnlichen planeten genau in der zone
Umkreis der habitablen wir kennen sie in der leben möglich ist und er ist uns relativ
Nahe 11 lichtjahre ist das system mit dem exoplaneten ross
128 b entfernt und auch aus 128 b
umkreist einen roten zwerg der für seine strahlungs ausbrüche bekannt ist und leben auf proxima centauri b
wahrscheinlich unmöglich macht das ist mit vier lichtjahren entfernung der nächste exoplaneten zurzeit aber ross
128 ist ein ruhiger roter zwerg der leben in seinem orbit ermöglichen würde jetzt rückt der
exoplaneten den fokus der forschungsteams weltweit die entfernung zum roten zwerg lässt temperaturen von minus 60
Plus 20 grad vermuten und die strahlung ist dort noch 138 mal so hoch wie hier auf der erde
obwohl der planet 20 mal mehr um seinen stern kreist der roten zwerg ist nämlich deutlich kälter als die sonne was damit trotz der nähe
leben auf ross
128 b ermöglichen würde er ist ein sanfter roter zwergs
128 b braucht übrigens nur rund zehn tage um seinen stern zu kreisen falls es dort
jahreszeiten gebe wir haben sie gerade mal zweieinhalb tage lang naja wetter wird und wohl etwas anders sein als hier auf der erde aber jetzt
kommt noch ein hammer horst
128 ist auf dem weg zu uns in für astronomische zeiträume extrem kurzer zeit wird ja schon unser nächster nachbar sein
in knapp
80.000 jahren ist es soweit jetzt heißt es warten aber nicht 80.000 jahre sondern auch anderthalb jahre dann wird nämlich das james webb
weltraumteleskop ins all geflogen und mit diesem revolutionären
teleskop können biomarker gefunden werden also anzeichen für leben wenn es
vielleicht auch schon früher
Neues zu dieser entdeckung gibt und vielleicht auch
Zu den seltsamen signalen von dort dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier drückt mehr dazu hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dem video signale von
Außerirdischen empfangen draufklicken wenn er mehr über die seltsame signale von ross 128 erfahren wollt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran